hello everyone my name is debo jyoti
chakraborty
i am from the csr institute of genomics
and integrative biology in new delhi
india
and today i am going to talk to you
about
recent work where we have used crispr
system through an affinity based method
uh as a diagnostic for resource limited
settings
we have been using it
for multiple different applications
for
the detection of the star scope to
infection
as well as for a single nucleotide
variant such as those found in diseases
or such as those which are signatures of
variance of current concern
so i'll give you a little bit of
background as to where we started from
uh my lab has been working extensively
with dr shobik mighty
in trying to characterize
an orthogonal caste system from francis
novicita
this was a high a very naturally
occurring highly specific cas9 which we
reported in this paper in pnas in 2019
it had a low editing efficiency inside
cell
however
under in vitro condition
what we did find out was that it had
certain interesting properties due to
which it was very very specific
in distinguishing two dna substrates
which were different by even a single
mismatch why this protein has evolved
differently or what are the structural
differences between other cancers and
this is a matter of ongoing
investigation
but what we clearly saw was that if you
present it two substrates which are
different in their sequence by in this
case as you see in this agarose gel
electrophoresis by two nucleotides of
three nucleotides
whereas
the canonical cast line from
streptococcus biogenes would be cleaving
these off targets which are mismatched
the francis illinois the cas9 would not
be cleaving
we later on uh found out that not only
was this gas line able to distinguish
between the substrates on the basis of
in vitro keyways but also they are not
binding to these mismatched substrates
meaning that the specificity is also
extendable at the level of interrogating
with these substrates
hence the the presentation is termed as
affinity based crispr diagnostics
this is what is the basis for the feluda
platform
uh the full form of feluda is fn cas9
editor-linked uniform detection assay
and the name actually is an acronym
which
is also the name of a fictional
detective character uh who is very
common uh commonly seen and quite famous
in uh in bengali literature creation of
the city three
this particular technology was also
licensed during the covet times for
detection of kovid non-exclusively and a
company called tata medical and
diagnostics came out with the product
that was validated
and approved in india for commercial use
by the drugs controller
general of india
uh sometime in
in september last year
so how does saluda actually work as you
will see that the principle of mismatch
discrimination happens
at the level of the cas9 rnp interacting
with the target dna
so what we figured out is that if the
guide rna which is very similar to the
guide rna as streptococcus pyrogenes
cas9 in terms of the way that the
complex interacts with dna if this
particular guide rna has bulges due to
mismatches
the fn casino protein is unable to
interrogate with the dna substrate
anymore
and precisely we can walk along the
whole length of this guide and find out
which are the points or which are the
positions where this loss happens
maximally and this has been then taken
into account for designing specific
guide rna
that can then distinguish two nucleotide
sequences different by even a single
mismatch
so therefore if the cache line is an
active form of gas mine or a new
clears form of casement it recognizes
the dna and then it cleaves the dna
and such a readout can then be used
either on an agarose gel electrophoresis
or it can also be used through a
capillary electrophoresis technique
however if you are using a nucleus
deficient form of this gas protein
which simply binds to the dna but
doesn't leave it then in that case the
affinity can be used to discriminate
between
fully max substrate versus a single
mismatch
later on as i will show you this can
also be converted into a fluorescence
based or a paper strip based essay of
readout very similar to that of a
pregnancy test kit
now
what we found out was that this high
power of discrimination can be used to
detect
of course dna as well as rna one
involves uh in vitro transcription um or
a step where the rna is converted a
reverse transcription step into where
rna is converted into dna
it works on a stoichiometric scale where
uh even the
binding based assay can be converted
into a method by which one can
distinguish even zygosity so
heterozygous um smps can also be
detected such as those seen in carriers
of the sickle cell mutation
so in order to convert it into a
fluorescent uh assay we use a
fluorescently labeled form of gas line
and then
you know by binding to the substrate
which would be biotin labels one can
then detect it by a fluorescence
detector
or in the case of a sickle cell for
carrier screening where the the carrier
screening is extremely important uh for
preventing the growth of sickle cell
disease because it uh happens only in a
homozygous state so if you can do
counseling at a level of carriers then
it is very useful
so we could also detect with hundred
percent success uh in blinded samples uh
both the homozygous as well as insecure
cell uh disease
uh during the same time our colleagues
from the all india institute of medical
sciences in new delhi
came up with this interesting
proposition whether we can detect point
mismatches in the helicobacter pylori
infection in patients which causes a
peptic ulcer
now this helicobacter pylori is
generally can be treated with certain
types of antibiotics but in some special
cases when this particular bacteria has
got point mutations in them they become
antibiotic resistant
and in such cases these
samples have to be then cultured and
after three to four days one knows
whether it is an antibiotic resistant
form of the bacteria or not now that is
not
very useful because that takes a lot of
time in the in the lab
if we do a failure assay on this which
can detect this point mutations very
efficiently we can actually bring down
this whole time to just an hour or one
and a half hours instead of this three
to four days and we could develop a
technique or an assay also for
helicobacter pylori
finally we wanted to see whether this
kind of an approach can work in the
field and as you uh some of you might
know that the sickle cell anemia is is a
big
health burden in india as if it is in
several other countries and
unfortunately most of the people who are
affected by this disease come from
tribal areas
where the access to health care
diagnosis is very poor and normally in
such places
the solubility test where a very crude
estimate of whether the person might be
a sickle or a carrier uh is done by
taking blood samples from individuals
and then looking at the precipitation
on the top left we are seeing how the
solubility test is performed and on the
top right we are having a snapshot of a
tertiary health care center which is a
primary school in this case where
children are lined up to see you know to
have their fingers strict and the blood
taken out
some of them like that little girl as
you can see over there who doesn't have
slippers on uh is seems a little bit uh
circumspective in trying to see what is
happening there
and what we found out that we do not
really need to use blood for failure we
can simply ask them to spit into a small
tube as is shown in the in the picture
at the bottom
and then this this tube actually
contains the the molecules that are
necessary
for breaking open the cells for the dna
to come out and then
the failure assay can actually be done
on them very easily so one can then
detect whether this person is a sticker
or a carrier
so we were basically trying to work on
these principles to develop
tests which can be used uh in the field
and this is when the the covid19
pandemic actually struck
and we decided that if it can work uh
well for single nucleotide polymorphisms
or variants we can actually also make it
work for detecting the covid19 signature
in a patient sample
where the most widely used technology is
of course reverse transcription pcr
so to convert this into an assay for
detecting the sars kovid
infection what we then did is that
we developed a pipeline where the
failure can be done on a paper strip
i will come to the technical details in
the next slide how this works but
essentially a person's sample is taken
either from the saliva or the
nasopharyngeal swab
and then
what we do is the rna is extracted from
these samples by breaking open the cell
and after the rna is extracted there is
a single step a reverse transcription
and pcr
where the pcr reaction is carried out
using biotin label primers now because
of the biotinylation in the primers the
amplicons that are generated have biotin
labels on both sides
and these biotin labeled amplicons then
serve as a substrate for the crispr
complex to bind to and give a signal on
a paper strip
i will explain the details on the next
slide but the major advantages of using
this is that it has got almost three
layers of specificity where the reverse
primer the forward primer and finally
the high specificity of the gas line
make sure that we can actually detect
only the right amplicon
uh it is of course rapid the entire
assay can be done within an hour uh it
is economical because it doesn't require
a real-time pcr instrument but rather a
normal pcr machine or even an isothermal
amplification where no machine is
required
um it is semi-quantitative as opposed to
some the collateral cleavage based
assays um which uses different forms of
gas
and it doesn't require any specialized
equipment like that of the real-time
instrument
now how does this work on the paper
strip so what we have used here is the
affinity of the cast 9 or the fn cas9 to
bind to biotin label dna
now this kind of a commercial paper
strip has got gold nanoparticles right
at the bottom
which
are conjugated with antibodies which
recognize the fam motif or fluorescence
amide motive
and what we have done in the cas9 rnp is
that we have
added a fam label to the three prime end
of the guide rna thus the rnp complex
now has a fam on one end
these gold nanoparticles can recognize
this family
when we do the biotin labeled amplicon
if there is a positive amplification
which means that there is a
the patient is positive for forward
infection
then the cas9 can recognize that this is
a nucleus deficient format of cas9 it
can recognize that
target and bind to it
thus the tertiary complex now has got
fam on one end which is at the level of
the guide rna and the biotin at the
other end which is at the level of the
dna amplicon to which it is found
when this is recognized by the anti-sam
antibody conjugated gold nanoparticles
in the strip
they together form another complex and
they start moving up by lateral flow in
the presence of a buffer now as it moves
up it reaches a area which you will see
marked in red also called the test band
in this test band region there is a high
concentration
of streptavidin the streptavidin
recognizes the biotin labeled complex
and it gets deposited over there forming
a colored band
if the sample was negative and there was
no presence of sarcoid signature then
the entire complex moves up and there is
a control band which recognizes the
anti-fem antibodies and therefore will
give a band on the top
and this band should form regardless of
whether the sample is positive or
negative and thus serves as the control
for the assay
in order to make this work fine we
needed to develop uh the guide rna in a
chimeric fashion where the three prime
can be fam labeled uh and it can be then
formed in a chimeric one along with the
cas9 and we needed to find out what
would be the degree of overlap in the
case of the sgrna because this has never
been tested for f and gas now
we found out the exact conditions for
this to happen which would allow the gas
line complex to form and successfully
recognize the target as you can see over
here uh showing the the overlap of the
tracer rna crna which is best suited at
19 nucleotides of overlap and then using
that we could develop this assay where a
typical assay would have this kind of
strips with two bands the bottom band is
called the test fan telling you that a
sample is positive the upper band is the
control band which will form in every
string
so using this principle we adapted this
for stars forward we went through the
entire genome
of saskowitz found out regions which are
conserved and not present in other viral
or human sequences
figured out what would be the right
concentrations of temperature as well as
primer concentrations
and also found out that this particular
assay was highly sensitive to just a few
copies of the target
rna in the initial sample
however since we are looking at a image
of a strip or we are we are looking at a
strip we
wondered if it might be possible to
convert this into an automated system so
to do that of of detection basically so
to do that we developed an app called
copy or true outcome predicted by a
strip evaluation which can be used to
simply take a picture of the strip and
this app has been trained by machine
language uh
where over several different types of
data to come up with a prediction
whether the sample is positive or
negative thereby reducing any kind of
operator bias in what one perceives as a
positive signal or a negative figure
we also developed a web tool called
jetta you junction for the analysis and
target design of your fedora experiment
where we the user can incorporate his
target sequence and the data you returns
the right primer sequences that would be
necessary to perform a failure
experiment so this is to support the
performance of a failure essay
we also made further improvements where
we could convert this whole thing into
just about half an hour or 45 minutes
using isothermal pcr using um our
recombinant polymers amplification or
rpa
where even without the need for any kind
of pcr machines just on a heating bar or
a heating block or a water bath one
could perform this even in a one pot
reaction where all the components will
be present together in the tube and this
could also be used to further reduce the
time as well as the the complexity
associated with diagnosis
this of course went ah was you know went
into the commercial spectrum and
currently this is known as tata md check
by the company which took this up
which uses this and it has been also
featured as a as a technology and these
are the people who have been principally
involved in developing this technology
this has now also
by the manufacturer has been converted
into a more mobile kind of a platform
where it is being used in different
parts of of india at different
destinations and different settings
and
the the method of methodology can be
adapted essentially to a large number of
different detection systems which we are
currently or less detection
outputs for different diseases which we
are also currently
exploring now
what happened during the pandemic was
that of course the sars kovit started
mutating and adapting to the different
selection pressure and therefore what we
had was variants these are the different
variants which had created havoc across
the world i think several of us are
aware of the delta variant which has
been uh kind of the most deadly and
these are mutants that is that mutations
that are normally arising in viral
sequences as the virus moves from one
post to the other
we figured out that uh you know normally
these variants would be you detected uh
majorly through
high throughput sequencing studies
and that is what is also being done
across the world
now one can do that but there are some
disadvantage when one does uh this kind
of high throughput dna sequencing for
diagnosis is that this is typically a
high cost experiment and it takes some
hours to actually get the result
typically this can be anywhere between
two to three days
a large number of samples needs to be
food in order to save on manpower and
cost
and
it is also only able to have a very uh
how to say robust calling mechanism for
mutations when the samples are very
concentrated which means that high city
values are often missed due to the
chemistry of the sequencing
methodologies
on the other hand rtpcr which is
relatively quick and the method of
choice for normal detection of covalent
sometimes can not work so well for point
mutation because the tachman probe
chemistry which works on binding to the
to the target has to be you know uh
extensively tested for mismatches and it
is not that efficient um for doing this
kind of mismatch based discrimination
so what we decided to come up with is a
platform where the crispr system due to
its high affinity
with full matches and very low affinity
with mismatches can be adapted to a
platform called a ray or rapid variant
assay
in which one could distinguish these
variants of concern as well on a paper
strip
so in order to do that we again took the
advantage that with a single um mismatch
or a complete match the cash line binds
to the substrate
whereas with a couple of mismatches the
cash line is evicting itself from the
substrate and it is relatively universal
in terms of discrimination across
multiple targets and multiple different
uh substrates that we have tested the
positioning of these mismatches thereby
we can actually adapt this very easily
for different types of targets
and
some of the targets that we specifically
chose for these applications were
mutational signatures of these variants
of concern
as the virus mutated it developed a new
kind of signatures and we tested this
methodology on the alpha variant first
which was the n501y
mutation
as you can see this variation appears in
the s gene of the virus and if you look
at the sequence shown over here on in
the slide the there is a nucleotide
which is a
highlighted in yellow in the sequence
which is the variant form of the
or let's say a signature of the variant
form of the virus which is the alpha
variable and by designing a guide which
would specifically be able to target uh
this
and another guide which would be able to
target the virus in itself we could use
the combination of these chips two
strips to be exact to come up with a
signal or an assay where if the the
guide is binding to both the n501y as
well as an other region which doesn't
get mutated then both the strips would
be positive telling that this is this
particular sample is an alpha variant on
the other hand if the guide binds only
to the wire type but doesn't bind
to the n501y mutant then one knows that
this sample is a kovid affected uh
positive sample but it is not positive
for the alpha variant and this is what
you see on the bottom in terms of uh
the reproducibility of the assay over
over different samples that it always is
able to distinguish between what is
called the n501y positive versus
negative samples
we of course used a large amplicon over
here and we found that there were some
problems if you use larger amplicons in
a pci reaction because sometimes the
amplification is not very very faithful
and it also takes a longer time for the
pcr reaction to complete so what we went
to was a double amplicon ray which were
very short amplicons that we made and
then the readout can be done on a paper
strip uh within a period of about 55
minutes so you can imagine that this is
several several fold orders faster in
magnitude than if you would do a
sequencing reaction we also came up with
ideas to figure out what would be the
right concentrations where to put the
biotin labels in these
amplicons and then we can see that up
till the ct value of close to 35 we can
specifically distinguish between a
substrate which is um uh
positive and also alpha variant negative
versus the substrate which is both
positive for infection as well as is a
variant of concern
because of the presence of the mutation
interestingly this particular technology
of variant detection can actually be
extended to cover the majority of
variance of concern because like i said
the mutations ah that need that are
detected and the presence of the
mismatches where it should be there on
the guide rna can actually is is quite
unifor universal so this means that the
mutation of signal signatures of all the
variants of concern
can be captured using this ray platform
and the s in cas9 due to the way that it
recognizes the dna can give the two
different types of signal where one it
is bound to the substrate strongly and
in the other case it is evicted from the
substrate
thus this is a platform that is not only
very useful for uh the variant of
concern for start forward diagnostics
but it is also useful if one wants to
use it for any kind of other single
nucleotide variants such as those found
in diseases or those associated with
certain types of traits um or those
which are just present in the dna and
one needs to detect them for a
particular asset
these kind of assays can help in
multiple ways one of the one of the ways
that it can
help is for early detection of variance
and this is something that we had
you know we can we had
[Music]
put forward in a landsat commentary
this year
where the variant diagnosis which
normally takes place by high support
sequencing can actually be streamlined
by having a initial cutoff based on a
rapid diagnostic platform such as
through crispr one can detect these
variant signatures and then can very
nicely
decide on the fate of such individuals
whether they need to be quarantined in a
stronger way or they need to be
quarantined in a normal of you know home
quarantine or they can be released
because certain variants are more
susceptible for transmission as has been
shown earlier than the other so these
are the type of streaming approaches
that one might potentially uh benefit
from if one has a diagnostic assays
which are so specific for detecting this
point mutation
so with that i come actually uh to the
most important slide which is the
acknowledgement slide and there are a
large number of people who have been
working on this
for a long period of time almost one and
a half years now uh during the entire
pandemic these are students post-doc
scientists
lab technicians
and
we are a big team who have been working
on this for a long period of time
actually
and we have been generally funded very
generously by different funding agencies
both government and non-government
and i'm extremely glad to get an
opportunity today to present this before
you
and would be happy
to address questions if you might have
based on this thank you very much